I think you're gonna see some dramatic
changes the way we think about these
cars and the accessibility in terms of
the price points and stuff but we're
still seven to ten years away from a
mass switchover
what can a politico market if you think
about a car what's a car a car has
batteries it has a computer it has a
motor and it has mechanical structure if
you look at an iPhone it has all the
same things even has a motor in it so if
you try to say and scale it up and go oh
my god I could make a car with those
same components there's some truth to
that but the hard stuff is really on the
connectivity and how cars could be
self-driving and those kinds of things
really hard and it's all software and
services I think that when you look at
either Google self-driving car program
or the alleged Apple thing it's all
looking at it through that lens of
software first did you ever talk to
Steve about building a car yes we had a
couple walks and this was in 2008 about
if we were to build a car what would we
build and we would just you know just
crazy like looking at Oh what would a
dashboard be and what would this be what
would seats be how would you feel it or
power it but at the end it was always
like we're so busy we're so constrained
we you know it would be great to do it
but we can't so when Steve was alive was
it something that he was like we're not
doing this we're not doing this right
now well there was a lot of things we
said no to you know people said well at
the end of the day why didn't we why
didn't the iPod turn into a really great
video camera TVs was another one for the
end of day what was the biggest one that
had the biggest dramatic impact on the
world was the cell phones and so we said
okay we're gonna focus all our energy on
that forget all this other stuff those
are interesting we'll let some other
company do it let's focus on really big
market that could have incredible impact
well beyond Steve's reign as CEO
Google's taking it on to with
self-driving cars yes it's great
they blow my mind every time I go over
there and talk to Chris or Sergey and
see what's going on and it feels like
I'm being driven around by a
professional driver regardless of
whether it's a taxi or uber or lyft or
any of these things you know I love
those services but most people
drive do not know how to drive they just
don't even if they do it every day for a
living they don't know how to draw their
that professional letter how do they
make these cars safe drive well but also
well-designed and desirable to me
self-driving cars have already caught up
with consumers because that's what
Hoover is it's a self-driving car it
just happens to be a person is driving
it so as far as I'm concerned they've
already made that choice now how do you
just make it even better and an even
more pleasurable experience